από ελπαλιόταν μων πιώμικρος ήταν ημέρα έκλειναν τα πράγματα για να πάμε όλι στο στρόμο
άλλες επόχες τώρα για γγια να πάει ο κόσμος στα στάτη στο στάδιο πρέπει α
τούμε για παράδειγμα νανε αγνο αςστο κυρόν πάσκετου ήταν πριλικές μέρες με τη γαλλία για
να δυσστόσον κόσμος να ήταν τα προκριματικάναπαράθερον προκριηματικών δεν είναι μόνο αυτό ο κόσμος έχει
αλλάει η πρωτερότετη χ έρχουν αλλάξει η τεχνολογία έχει αλλάξει δηλαδή μπορείς και με και
με τη βοήθεια της όμοσπονδίας έχουμε τοδικώ μας σύστημα αυτόμα των χαμερών το οποίων έχει
τοποθετητεί σε όλα τα γύπεδα τις πρώτης κατηγορίας αρά και από το κινηδώ σου μέσων
τις πλατφόρμας στις δικήματ μπορείς να δεις ένα παιχνίδη τηλειόραση και η επιλογή που έχεις
δηλαδή είναι τόσον τόσο δύσκολι και επιεστική καθημερινότητα που πλέουν βάλεις μια ν επιλογή πο
κάνει στην επιλογή άρα θα έχεις επιλογή να επιλέξεις εκείνο που θα σε ξεκουράσει θα
θα σουκινήσει των ιδιαφέρουν περιστότεν βεβαίος βλέπουμε τη αύξηση στον κόσμο που έρχετα στο κίμερο
θέλουμε και άλλους βεβαίος εννοίδε χρειάζετε μια μια συνέχεια και μια προσπάθεια από όλους και
από την ομοσπονδία και από τα ιδιανοσματα τα σοματία περακαταλάβουν ότι πρέπει να δινιουργήσουν κα
εκίνες στις συνθήκες ουτσωστε να προσελκήσουν τις οικογένειες δηλατία τους δώσουν κάτι περισσότερο από ένα
σανανταλεπτών αγώνα πρέπει να διμιουργήσουν των περιβάλλων ταν χώρον του που να δείχνουν διάφορές δρατηριότητες
να μπορεί οικογένεια να πάει τ που βλέπουν ε θε ποτις ερικούς θα γόνες κάποιες
και όχι μόνο και σε άλλα μπασκετικά γεγονότα ή σε άλλες σε άλλα πρωταθλήματα αλλά
να πω ότι ναι έχουν ξεκινήσει και δική μας ομάδες και κάνουν αυτό τω αυτές
τις δραστηριότητες όμως το σημείον κλιδεί είναι είναι οι αναίσεις είναι η υπε δικές ενγκαταστάσεις
όταν δεν έχεις γυπεδικές ανγκαταστάσεις μοντέρνες να έχεις το αποχωριτήριω ανδρν γυναικών και αμέα λέω
απλά πράγματα μια καίνα να μπορεί να προει